dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir with a recent
ascendancy of several new AI based
techniques for human facial reenactment
we are now able to create videos where
we transfer our gestures onto famous
actors or politicians and impersonate
them clearly as this only needs a few
minutes of video as training data from
the target this could be super useful
for animating photorealistic characters
for video games and movies reviving
legendary actors who are not with us
anymore and much more and understandably
some are worried about the social
implications of such a powerful tool in
other words if there are tools to create
forgery
there should be tools to detect forgery
right if we can train an AI to
impersonate why not train an other AI to
detect impersonation this has to be an
arms race however this is no easy task
to say the least as an example look here
some of these faces are real some are
fake what do you think which is which
I will have to admit my guesses weren't
all that great but what about you let me
know in the comments section compression
is also an issue since all videos you
see here on YouTube are compressed in
some way to reduce file size some of the
artifacts that appear may easily throw
off not only an AI but a human as well I
bet there will be many completely
authentic videos that will be thought of
as fakes by humans in the near future so
how do we solve these problems first to
obtain a neural network based solution
we need a large data set to train it on
this paper contains a useful data set
with over a thousand videos that we can
use to train such a neural network these
records contain pairs of original and
manipulated videos along with the input
footage of the gestures that were
transferred after the training step the
algorithm will be able to pick up on the
smallest changes around the face and
tell a forged footage from a real one
even in cases where we humans are unable
to do that this is really amazing
these green to red colors showcase
regions that the AI thinks were tampered
with and it is correct interestingly
this can not only identify regions that
are forgeries but it can also improve
these forgeries too I wonder if it can
detect footage that it has improved
itself what do you think thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time